mid-afternoon at a busy shopping mall in
Texas and dash cam video shows a man
step out of a car and start shooting
passers-by
What followed was the latest mass
shooting in a country divided over gun
violence Witnesses ran for cover we see
the guy there's this guy dressing all
black wearing a vest has an assault
rifle and he's just shooting at people
right across he was at like Francesca's
area shooting at people so we got
everyone in the store into the back of
the store and just camped out there
and then we just took her to the back
there was that people on the floor a lot
of people they were like you know hiding
and as I was going around they told me
to get away you know to move out and I
kept on telling them I'm looking for my
daughter police evacuated hundreds of
Shoppers from the mall in Allen just
north of Dallas the gunman was killed by
an officer who happened to be nearby the
motive is still unknown at 3 36 our
officer was at Allen Premium Outlets on
an unrelated call
he heard gunshots located The Gunshot
located the shooter neutralized the
shooter neutralized the threat
we believe at this point that the
shooter acted alone barely a week ago a
man in Cleveland Texas killed five of
his neighbor's most adults aged 21 or
over in the state are allowed to carry a
handgun without a license the city of
Allen is now in shock we are a strong
and caring community and we all want the
victims and their families impacted by
this tragedy to know that we will wrap
our arms around you and we are here for
you
this is the 199th mass shooting in the
United States this year that has left
four or more people dead or wounded
according to the gun violence archive
once again a community is in mourning
Thomas More Sky News